so you can see the heading is cubic
inequalities because we are looking at
these same cubic objects but it's not a
cubic equation I've got a greater than
zero here I've got a less than or equal
to zero here so when we solve these
things right do you notice this does not
require a graph so it does not require a
graph the graph is a tool for us right
so that's why I'm going to be a little
more fast and loose with this drawing
because it's a tool it's a means to an
end
okay now in order to say like the
solution of this in all these different
ways which we've been looking at in
functions so far in this topic right
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
think about this see this bunch of
symbols I'm going to interpret that in a
visual way okay so when I see this thing
greater than zero what I read is when is
this thing here right when is this
function and then it says greater than 0
greater than 0 so I mean above greater
than this x-axis here so when is this
function above the x-axis okay that's
the way I read that I look at those
symbols and I think oh there's a picture
hiding behind this that I can use to
help solve this okay now what we're
gonna do is really do a quick crash
course of how can we use this thing to
look at what this function looks like
and then I'm gonna find out where is it
above the axis right it's in a nice neat
factorized form so we should be able to
really quickly read off the x-intercepts
right how do you read them off how do
you use the factorized form any takers
think think think guys this is this
morning right I should be able to read a
solution from each factor right what's
the first one to just before you go on
I'm getting two from this guy here right
if I were to put x equals 2 into here
the whole thing would become 0 right so
that gives me an x intercept right you
can then read off what the other ones
are the next one John negative 1 very
good if I put negative 1 into here all
the rest of it becomes 0 so I have
another
intercept and my last one of course is
positive five thank you very much okay
now I'm gonna go from there straight
over to my Cartesian plane and I'm gonna
mark in those spots on the x-axis these
guys are my x-intercepts so I've got
let's see here there's negative 1 2
there's new there's 2 3 4 5 there we go
negative 1 2 5 so I've got my numbers on
there that I've read off of here ok now
in the morning we wondered if you get
these three intercepts right there are a
couple of different ways that the snake
of our graph can weave its way through
them right so it's going to be either
something that looks like this or
something that looks like this okay now
before what we do is we substitute some
values in to see what would happen okay
but in this case I'm just going to draw
your attention to the fact that were
right to expand this whole thing right
and don't do it I just want you to think
if you did have a look at the X cubed
term that's what makes this a cubic
right you're gonna get some X Squared's
you're gonna get some X's you're gonna
get a number at the end but only one
term will have an X cubed inner what
would be the sign in front of the X
cubed would it be a plus or a minus it's
gonna be positive now how could you tell
because you haven't actually expanded it
what did you use to work it out what do
you reckon
yeah very good there are known negatives
out in front of any of the X pronumerals
right so therefore since you've got
positive x positive x positive x no
matter what happens to the rest of it
your X cubes will be positive that means
you're gonna get this guy here right
because as you get bigger and bigger
values of X it's going to get more and
more positive to see that as opposed to
this guy here as you get bigger and
bigger values of X does it get more
positive no bingo it gets even more
negative so this is negative x cubed
this is positive execute so I pretty
much know all I need to know to now get
a rough graph through here it's gonna go
up right remember that and then it's
just going to kind of weave its way
around like this okay now at the moment
I've got all the X intercepts there and
I just used that to get a general shape
I hope you notice I haven't gotten the y
intercept
and at the end of this once we finished
answering the question I'm going to ask
you why I didn't bother to find it okay
but for now I'm gonna go back to this
blue riding right I now know what the
function looks like so the question is
asking when is that function above the
x-axis and you can kind of see those
portions country if you've got another
color I'd love you to grab that out and
whichever way you'd like let's highlight
the sections of this graph that are
above the axis can anyone tell me where
does the first section begin yeah this
which dips will you throw into between
where and where this top bit this guy
here well this guy here this one here is
where we start okay so I'm kind of going
to go from left to right so like
surrounded I'm gonna start at this
section here and I'm just going to mark
it in with another color just so I can
see it that part is clearly above the
axis so it agrees with what the question
is asking okay
I do of course have another section
where is it yeah over this part here so
this is all above the x-axis right above
y equals zero which is because this is a
y axis and this is an x axis right so
these are the parts I want have I got
them all I'm pretty happy with them okay
I've got a quick question for you right
my um my blue shading right it begins
and ends then it begins and then it just
keeps on going
okay am I allowed to include the actual
beginning and end now it does depend on
the question that you get in this case
the answer is no how could I tell how
could I tell yeah see this guy here what
this is saying is I want you to not just
be like on the axis you have to be above
the axis you're not allowed to equal it
so these guys here I'm gonna draw some
big hollow circles like so does that
make sense they're not included all
right now at this point the graph has
served its purpose I've worked out when
the function is above the x-axis so I'm
ready to answer these three questions
and States this blue thing in in the
terms that the vas could ask for
okay well but I've asked for so here we
go Part A
as an inequality so I've got this part
here and again this is looking at what
you did yesterday between negative 1 & 2
we can write this section in one fell
swoop with just a single sort of grouped
inequality can anyone tell me how am I
going to write this just hold that
thought or on you've had some good input
sorry today can someone else help me out
hmmm yeah what go ahead bless then now
before I write this next part right I
want to be between here and here
yeah so in other words that's greater
than negative one like zeroes okay
ones half so K ones okay but then do I
want to be greater than two
that's that way right so I actually
would be less than two yeah so I'm gonna
write lists and then I'm gonna write
less than again like so okay
here's two and in here within this
little boundary is the section that's
okay that I highlighted in blue right
because this is the part of graph that
is above the x-axis
yeah well this part isn't don't see that
part of it it's not yeah this one here I
haven't got to it yet
right so I'm just thinking at this bit
first is that okay